Hello, in this class we'll be learning about advanced nodes effects in translucent materials
and specifics to be aware of when applying them to our scenes.
There are no slides for this lesson, so let's jump straight into the engine.
Alright, we're in the blurred glass section of our default map, and here you can see
two different preview meshes with the same material assigned.
This material is supposed to be replicating a frosted glass look, and it's using a node
called Spiro Blur, which is actually a material function.
Now if I switch my mode from Lit to Shader Complexity, we can see that similarly to
the rest of our translucent material, this shader has a high computational cost, especially
if you start overlapping multiple translucent objects on top of each other.
That's really where it gets bright pink, which is the heaviest you can get.
The demand of this material doesn't just come from its translucency properties, but
also from the Spiro Blur node itself that it was created with, which has a quite
high performance overhead.
So make sure to use it with caution in your environments if you plan on using this
material.
Ok, we have our preview mesh selected, and now in the details panel we can just double
click on the material assigned to it to open it up.
Ok, I'm just gonna undock it over here, and then I'm gonna just zoom a little bit
into this plane.
Now we have two values that we can play around with in this material instance.
One is the amount, and the other one is connected to the temporal anti-aliasing radial
blur.
Now if we slide around the temporal AA, we can see that it's not really affecting
the visuals of this material.
And that's probably because it should be used in conjunction with other settings and parameters
of the spiral blur that weren't exposed to the material instance.
So I'm just gonna turn it off and focus on the amount.
So if we focus on these defined outlines of the cube, which is behind this plane,
and then I start increasing the amount value or the intensity of my blur, you can see
that the outlines of the cube become less and less perceivable.
And as I slide it down, they get real crisp and defined.
Let's stop this material instance back here, and open up its parent material to see how
it was developed.
Alright, so we kept this material quite simple, and really most of it revolves around
this spiral blur material function.
Now this node being a material function allows us to double click on it, and then open it
up and see how it was developed.
This is a really cool technique to peek under the hood of the engine and see how
its developers developed this expression.
Now it's really important that we keep these material functions intact and we don't
apply any changes to them because they're directly connected to the engine content.
So if you move some nodes around or if you unplug some pins, make sure to either reconnect
them or when you close down this material function to not save any changes.
Alright, talking about the spiral blur material functions, we actually have two different
nodes that we can use based on our needs.
If we right-click in an empty area of the graph and we type spiral blur, we can see
that we can either select the texture option or the scene texture.
And I'm just going to pop off of them here.
Now the textures parabola is really connected to textures and image samples, while the
scene texture is connected to the camera and the scene.
Now as I just mentioned, we kept this material quite simple.
And we also haven't exposed a lot of its settings to parameters.
So we don't have them at our disposal here in the material instance.
But this doesn't mean that you can't go in and expose them yourself, change the color
and just test out the settings of this spiral blur.
So the aim of this lesson was really to spark your curiosity and demonstrate yet
another kind of look and feel that you can achieve using translucent materials.
That was it for this lesson and in the next video, we'll be learning about two-sided
foliage materials and how they're set up.
I'll see you there.